And you see people of great age with like they look,
they're just ripped and you look at what they're eating,
like fish,
rice,
vegetables,
and it's all lean,
smart food.
And the sugars are all,
uh,
monosaccharides,
like fruit,
sugar,
you know,
the occasional banana or orange is a treat.
But you know,
the sugar is really not in the Diet at all.
Maybe Rice should be,
you know,
but not like we are doing it.
No.
Now,
no one's ever done it my,
the way we were doing it and no one's ever been as fat,
you know.
And then we have these things to shield people from,
we call it fat shaming,
you know,
don't tell someone their fat and let them just be morbidly obese and go through
life at a massive risk of heart attack or stroke or diabetes.
Don't say anything because then you'll hurt their feelings.
And while you,
you could say something to someone and it might be uncomfortable in the moment
of,
Hey Mike,
um,
listen,
I don't want to be that guy,
but you got to lose some weight.
And then that guy could go and look in the mirror and go,
fuck,
I really do need to lose some weight.
And then they'll lose some weight and there'll be healthy and they'll talk to
you four or five months later and go,
you know,
you fucked my head up that day.
And because of that,
I really started changing the way I eat and I'm so much healthier and I feel
better.
And because he's your friend,
my friend Tom Seger and,
and Bert Kreischer,
they did this thing last year,
well,
two years ago where they did,
they had a weight loss competition.
And uh,
one of the things they kept doing is fat shame each other like ruthlessly.
And they would use Hashtag bird is fat,
Hashtag Thomas Fat.
And they had this weight loss competition.
Oh.
And they fucking both laws a shitload of weight.
I think they both lost between 50 and 60 pounds and they looked fucking
incredible.
But then after it was over,
Tom was like,
dude,
let me tell you something.
Fat Shaming works.
It works.
It got me off my ass.
I realized I was a fat fuck.
And it made me lose weight.
It doesn't feel good.
That shaming thing is you like fat shaming doesn't work on people weren't fat.
Okay,
it works on people who have a problem but don't want to address that problem.
So you bring up that problem and then they go,
oh,
you're making me feel bad by thinking about my problem.
You're a bad person.
No,
you have a weak spot.
That weak spot shouldn't be there.
I've got it.
Shouldn't,
you shouldn't Belabor it and constantly ridicule someone for being fat.
But the idea that you're never supposed to bring it up,
even with someone you care about,
even in jest or friends busting balls like,
no,
no.
You should bring it up because that,
that bad feeling is a gift.
It makes you realize like,
Oh my God,
I've been remiss.
I haven't been paying attention to my own physical sovereignty.
You know,
I have control over what goes in my body.
I have control over the,
the,
the amount of calories I take in the kind of calories I have control over how
much body fat I'm carrying around and there's ways to fix it.
Yeah,
I think you should,
uh,
use discretion.
Yes.
And she got in line at the supermarket and to sue people you'd like,
you know,
it's just,
but it was funny to hear Tom,
he was getting angry.
He's like fucking fat shaming man.
All these people that say don't fat shame.
Fuck.
That's how I got skinny fat shaming works until you know.
But you know,
again,
yes,
don't be rude to someone out in public for no reason to drive an 11 year old to
suicide.
Definitely don't do that.
Well there are little kids is the worst cause like their parents will get them
hooked on those sugary sodas and once it's the God damn sodas man,
I mean that is one of the primary causes for people being fat in this country.
And it just seems so innocuous.
It's just an a class,
I'll just drink this.
It's got some ice cubes.
No big deal goes down so fast,
tastes great.
And the weekends,
um,
I,
I like ginger beer and that the Bundaberg,
it's this same power as a coke.
I mean,
it's a lot of sugar.
And I,
I,
uh,
buy a four pack and I have one bottle a week,
Saturday night,
my big drink,
like,
Ooh,
discipline.
He's going nuts.
Look at him,
he's got his drink,
the best tasting stuff.
But man,
it tastes good for a reason.
It's so sweet and like,
you just want the next one when you're done.
But man,
I,
and I could drink them all day,
but I just can't do that to my system.
So I do one a week.
That's good discipline.
Yeah.
But it's like,
you know,
he something to look forward to.